>> Todd: MORE THAN 1,000
MIGRANTS CAMPING OUT IN EL PASO,
TEXAS, AS TEMPERATURES THERE
DROP BELOW FREEZING AND MIGRANT
SHELTERS ARE OVERRUN.
THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY ARE
FOCUSING THEIR EFFORTS ON SUING
ARIZONA OVER THEIR MAKESHIFT
BORDER WALL SAYING NOT ONLY HAS
EARLZ REFUSED TO TRESPASSES AND
REMOVED SHIPPING CONTAINERS FROM
FEDERAL LANDS INDICATED IT WILL
CONTINUE TO TRESPASS ON FEDERAL
LANDS AND INSTALL ADDITIONAL
SHIPPING CONTAINERS.
THE UNITED STATES BRINGS THIS
ACTION TO OBTAIN APPROPRIATE
RELIEF FOR ARIZONA'S UNLAWFUL
CONTINUING TRESPASSES.
>> Carley: U.S. DEPUTY ASSISTANT
SECRETARY JONATHAN FAHEY JOINS
US NOW.
CAN YOU BELIEVE A WEEK BEFORE
TITLE 42 THAT'S WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MOVES TO SUE
ARIZONA OVER BUILDING THIS
BORDER WALL?
WHAT KIND OF TIMING IS THAT?
>> YEAH.
SADLY, I CAN BELIEVE IT BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE THING THEY DO IS TO
PREVENT BORDER U.
ENFORCEMENT.YOU DO WANT TO SAY S
UNBELIEVABLE THEY WOULD DO THIS
BUT IT REALLY IS SO PREDICTABLE
ANY EFFORT TO ENFORCE THE LAW
THEY WILL STAND IN THE WAY AND
IMPEDE.
REMEMBER, THIS ADMINISTRATION
WAS JUST IN FRONT OF THE SUPREME
COURT A FEW WEEKS AGO FIGHTING
TO KEEP AGGRAVATED FELONS IN THE
COUNTRY, FIGHTING A LAW THAT
TOLD THEM TO DEPORT THEM.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING THEY CAN
TO PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS ENCOURAGE
AS MUCH ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AS
THEY CAN BECAUSE THEY WANT AN
OPEN BORDERS AND LATER THEY WANT
MASS AMNESTY.
SO, IT'S REALLY DISGRACEFUL.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE EFFORTS
GOING INTO THIS, THESE EFFORTS
ARE ACTUALLY GOING IN TO ENFORCE
A LAW TO MAKE THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS BETTER TO PREVENT
DRUGS FROM COMING IN?
THEY ARE NOT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE SPENDING
THEIR TIME ON.
IT'S REALLY DISGRACEFUL.
>> Todd: THE PEOPLE IN THE
TRENCH REALIZE THAT THEY ARE
FRUSTRATED.
DHS SECRETARY ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
REPORTEDLY NOT GETTING A NOT SO
WARM WELCOME FROM BORDER AGENTS
IT DURING HIS TRIP TO EL PASO.
WHEN HE STATED HE WAS HERE TO
BRING LIGHT TO SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND NOTHING ABOUT THE
MIGRANT CRISIS OUR STAFF
COULDN'T BELIEVE IT AND MADE IT
KNOWN TO HIM.
ANOTHER AGENT ADDED QUOTE THEY
ASKED HIM WHY HE IS SAYING THE
BORDER IS SECURE WHEN THERE ARE
NO AGENTS IN THE FIELD.
HE HAD THE NERVE TO SAY HE NEVER
SAID THE BORDER WAS SECURE.
ISN'T IT LONG PAST TIME FOR
MAYORKAS TO GO ESPECIALLY WHEN
HE HAS LOST THE PEOPLE THAT HE
IS SUPPOSED TO LEAD SO BADLY?
>> YEAH.
HE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT BE IN
THAT JOB.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS
ADMINISTRATION LOVES HIM BECAUSE
HE IS DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN TO
KEEP THIS BORDER OPEN.
AND, YOU SEE IT RIGHT THERE.
HE IS WILLING TO LIE TO THE
PEOPLE IS HE RESPONSIBLE FOR
LEADING THAT ARE ENTRUSTED UNDER
HIS CARE.
AND HE IS WILLING TO LOOK AT
THEM AND LIE.
AND ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WAS REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
THAT ARTICLE THAT I READ THIS
MORNING WAS HE TALKS ABOUT WE
WANT TO ENFORCE THE LAW
CONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES,
WHICH BASICALLY -- I CAN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING MORE INSULTING TO
SAY BECAUSE THE IMPLICATION IS
EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN ENFORCING
THE LAW IS DOING SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH OUR
VALUES, IT'S IMMORAL.
AND, REMEMBER, THIS
ADMINISTRATION JUST A YEAR AGO,
WAS LYING ABOUT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ACCUSING THEM OF WHIPPING
MIGRANTS.
AND EVEN AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED AS LIARS, THEY HAVE
NEVER COME BACK AND EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THEY LIED
ABOUT THEM.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO PUNISH
THOSE BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS HAVE NO
REASON TO TRUST THIS
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THIS ADMINISTRATION LOOKS AT
THEM WITH UTTER DISDAIN.
IT CAN'T BE ANYTHING MORE
HORRIBLE THAN BEING IN A
POSITION THEY ARE IN.
THEY TALK ABOUT MORALE BEING
LOW.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE NO MORALE
WHATSOEVER BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL LOOK TO
HARM THEM IF THEY DO THEIR JOB.
IT'S REALLY, AGAIN, JUST SO
DISGRACEFUL.
>> Jillian: JONATHAN, MORE THAN
A THOUSAND MIGRANTS RIGHT NOW
ARE CAMPING OUTSIDE IN EL PASO,
TEXAS, BECAUSE ALL OF THE
SHELTERS ARE OVERWHELMED.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE OVER THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS THAT'S
UNFOLDING THERE?
>> YEAH, WELL, AGAIN, THEY DO
NOT CARE ABOUT THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS, THEY WANT AS MANY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO COME TO
THE COUNTRY AS POSSIBLE.
THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY'RE BEING
HUMAN TRAFFICKED.
THEY DON'T CARE THIS COINCIDES
WITH MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER THAT
WILL KILL AMERICANS.
THEY DON'T CARE ONE BIT ABOUT
THIS.
THE ONLY TIME WE HAVE SEEN SEEN
THEM CARE ABOUT THIS WAS WHEN
THEY TOOK ABOUT 48 OF THEM AT
THE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEN UP IN ARMS AND DO
SOMETHING.
WHEN THEY ARE IN EL PASO OR
OTHER STATES, THEY COULD CARE
LESS.
AND YOU ARE NOT GOING TO HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
YOU TAKE BILL MELUGIN OFF THE
GROUND AND FOX NEWS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULDN'T EVEN
KNOW THIS IS GOING ON, WHICH IS
REALLY ANOTHER AMAZING ASPECT OF
THIS STORY HOW THE MEDIA IS JUST
COMPLICIT AND INCURIOUS.
>>